have you read it so she just have to
keep watching everyone jiseok always
have with you
absolutely yes now my niece he'll feel
yourself
you
all right welcome back everyone okay so
I have a website now you can all log on
to or just go to my website that's
faculty dot washington d d u /s Brunton
/m e 564 and you'll have a list sorry
the resolution is completely bombed
right now you have video lectures so you
can go and actually watch these recorded
lectures if you want you can download
them in HD they're about a gig each um
the homeworks will be posted there's no
homeworks actually posted right now I
think I'll probably post the first
homework sometime over the weekend or on
Monday it'll be due on next Friday
and it'll cover material through the
Wednesday lecture of next week okay this
should be mostly introductory stuff so
hopefully it's not going to be too
intense and it's not going to be like
super long either anything else
yeah so I actually post all of the
lecture notes and syllabus online so
this is going to keep developing every
time I give a lecture I'm just going to
add a line here discussing what I do
there's a link to the PDF notes that
I've scanned in and any MATLAB codes
that I generate so for example right now
you can actually download the notes for
today I've already downloaded them and
these are all my notes for today okay
okay I think that's it for the board for
the the computer any questions about the
class now that everyone's had a little
bit of a chance to think about things No
okay so today I'm going to do a few
things this is going to be a pretty
important lecture because this is really
where a lot of the review for the class
will take place and in the next lectures
we're just going to keep building kind
of faster and faster until we saturate
okay so I'm going to give you a little
overview of the topics I'm going to
discuss today
now some of this is definitely going to
be review for a lot of you but I'm
hoping that pretty quickly we'll get
into things that most of you hasn't seen
before
okay so first we're going to review some
calculus okay so this will include the
derivative the power law and the chain
rule okay this will be pretty quick I'm
going to start talking about the
simplest Oh de so the simplest Oh de
which is just X dot equals lambda X so
we're going to think about where this
comes up in physical systems engineering
systems we're going to look at a few
different ways of solving this I can
think of three off the top of my head
we'll do two of them today we're going
to talk a little bit more about what is
the exponential e and this might sound
really really simple but this is
extremely important okay so you know all
of these concepts are going to be
extremely familiar by the end of this
class we're going to be using these
everyday as if we're adding numbers okay
and then the fourth topic is solving
this equation X dot equals lambda X
using Taylor series
okay and there's a good chance that
number four will actually be something
we do on Monday okay
so this is probably for the next lecture
okay so that's just what I want you to
kind of have in the back of your mind
this is the progression we're going to
solve simple OD es starting with X dot
equals lambda X we're going to think
about lots of ways to do this pretty
quickly I want to get into very general
ways of solving this where we actually
derive the solution instead of just you
know use tricks from calculus and then
we're just going to build it up to
systems and nonlinear systems quickly so
any any questions about about this nope
okay and feel free to interrupt at any
time that's totally fine with me
all right good so everyone's taking
calculus some of us have taken it
multiple times or in different contexts
and so you've all seen the derivative
and the integral and I'm just going to
kind of briefly go over just to brush up
I know some of you it's been a while and
so we're just going to kind of get all
get on the same page of what the
derivative means physically and
geometrically and mathematically okay
okay good so what does the derivative
mean anyone okay the rate of change of a
function perfect rate of change of a
function with respect to what yeah with
respect to X I probably shouldn't post
my notes while I'm giving giving the
lecture okay so this has a super super
simple geometric interpretation okay
and this should be something really
familiar to all of us you know there's a
ton of calculus I forgotten I'm going to
be completely honest right there's just
a tremendous amount of calculus that I
learned and don't remember but you can
almost derive everything if you know a
few first principles okay so when I
teach my undergrads you know I teach
them more formulas I want you to know
first principles ten years from now 20
years from now it doesn't matter what
formulas you remember it matters that
you can derive things from first
principles okay so we have some function
f of X we care about looking at the
derivative at some point X and we think
that the derivative means the rate of
change of F with respect to X and that
means the slope of the tangent line at
that point X okay so we can do a pretty
good job of approximating this
derivative DF DX this is going to
approximately equal F at X plus Delta X
okay so this is X plus some little Delta
X away Delta X is small minus f of X
divided by Delta X that's just a formula
for how much does the F variable change
over DX okay DF DX is approximately this
and if we make Delta X smaller and
smaller and smaller so we bring this
point closer and closer and closer we
converge to the true derivative of that
function at X okay so usually we put
this limit as Delta X goes to zero and
now this isn't approximately equal it's
exactly equal okay that's the derivative
okay super important stuff
it's blew everyone's mind when Newton
and Leibnitz came out with it let's
change the world ever since hey that's
the derivative we're going to use this a
lot we're going to take it for granted a
lot but I don't want you to take it for
granted so a lot of times we're going to
drop this limit and we're just going to
assume that Delta X is small okay so in
calculus we always take this limit as
Delta X goes to zero and we do
mathematical things we're going to do a
lot of things in the computer and we're
going to think that the derivative is
approximately equal to this difference
divided by DX for a small but finite DX
okay okay good so now we're just going
to do this on a simple example of a
function X to the N and we're going to
derive the power law so this should be
one of the straightforward things we can
do in calculus okay so we're going to
try f of x equals x to the n and this is
called the power law okay so we all know
what the derivative of x to the N is
it's DF DX equals n times X to the N
minus 1 but we can derive it pretty
simply from this formula over here okay
so I'm going to say DF DX is
approximately equal to 1 over Delta x
times F at X plus Delta X so that's X
plus Delta X to the N minus f of X which
is just
to the N okay this is f of X plus Delta
X okay so how many of you remember how
to take X plus Delta X to the nth power
there's a few ways to do it lots of ways
anybody
there's this guy his name started with a
P Pascal right there's a programming
language named after him so Pascal's
triangle kind of gives you a quick and
dirty formula for computing this you can
also use the binomial expansion and you
get so 1 over Delta x times let's try
not to mess this up
X to the N ok that's the first term then
the second term you're going to you know
do all this multiplication and collect
all of the X to the N minus 1 terms and
you're going to have n of them times the
Delta X then you're going to have an N
times n minus 1 divided by 2 times X to
the N minus 2 Delta x squared plus dot
dot dot bunch more terms right and plus
one of them and then we still have this
term left over minus X to the N ok good
so this is just using Pascal's triangle
or binomial expansion my X to the N is
cancel and I'm left with 1 over Delta X
times all of the stuff in the middle so
that's n X and minus 1 times Delta X
plus n times n minus 1 over 2 X to the N
minus 2 Delta x squared plus I don't
want to write all this other stuff down
so I'm going to say everything else is
on the order of Delta X cubed so Delta X
cube Delta X to the fourth to the fifth
and so on so it's on the order of Delta
X cubed and higher okay and now what I'm
finally going to do is I'm actually
going to divide out my Delta X now and
take the limit as Delta X goes to 0 so
we have n X to the N minus 1 plus a
bunch of stuff that's order Delta X and
this goes to 0 when Delta X goes to 0
okay so starting with a very simple
physical definition of the derivative
it's the rate of change of F with
respect to X the slope of this tangent
line using this formula and then
essentially plugging in any function we
like we can derive the derivative okay
this should be review for most for most
of you if it's not you should do this on
a few functions and get a feel for this
okay okay any questions that the
derivative or the power law yeah I'm
sorry
yeah so I had these order Delta X cubed
terms I also had order delta x squared
so when I divide by Delta X I have an
Delta X plus Delta x squared plus Delta
X cubed and I lump them all into this
term yes so sorry I'm being a little
fast and loose with this notation this
just means I have this term which is not
multiplied by Delta X and then
everything else is multiplied by at
least 1 Delta X maybe more okay so those
all get limited to 0 yeah good question
okay so another super important kind of
calculus rule that you can derive is
called the chain rule this is the most
important in my opinion okay and that
just says that the derivative with
respect to X of a function f of another
function G of a variable X is equal to F
prime of G of X times G prime of X and
prime just means derivative DF DX ok
prime is a means derivative so this is
really really important the chain rule
this is how we solve complicated
calculus problems right you could do
like sine of X cubed and you could find
the derivative using the chain rule ok
so again if this is something that you
know you've seen before but you don't
really feel super comfortable let's just
try a couple of functions like that get
the hang of it you can always check them
on Wolfram Alpha to make sure you're
doing it correctly okay okay good now
let's get serious here now we're going
to start talking about differential
equations so calculus is one of the
fundamental language languages that we
use to communicate what we observe
things change in time things change with
respect to variables and now we're going
to figure out how to use that to solve
essentially to do problem solving to
model the real world
okay so differential equations is
probably along with probability the most
useful technique for modeling the real
world we have okay so I always like to
start with a really really simple
example to motivate ordinary
differential equations we're going to
come up with a bunch that are relevant
for for things that we do but let's say
that we start with a population of
bunnies okay so X is the size of a
population of bunnies okay and what do
we know that Bunny is like to do
procreate right
bunnies procreate and so what we have is
the size of the population X changes at
a rate that's proportional to the size
of the population the more bunnies the
more procreation the more baby bunnies
okay and so the population changes in
time this is DX with respect to time
we're going to call that X dot so dot is
specially used for time derivatives DX
DT equals X dot this is going to be
proportional to the size of the
population okay this is our simplest
differential equation X dot equals
lambda X
okay now there are a lot a lot of other
ways to solve this
the basic question we're going to ask is
what is the size of the population X as
a function of time okay how does this
population change in two years three
years four years five and a half years
any time you specify I want to be able
to tell you how many bunnies there are
if I know how fast they procreate okay
okay so how do I solve this problem what
are some ways to do this great ok it's
separate variables it integrates that's
a good idea let's try that okay
okay so separating the variables and
integrating basically means keep all of
the X's and D X's on one side
move all of the T's and D T's to the
other side and then integrate both sides
right okay so we have DX DT equals
lambda X and so that basically means
that I have I can divide both sides by X
and have DX over x equals lambda DT
right and if I integrate both sides of
this with respect to X on the left and
with respect to T on the right then
what's the integral of DX over X law
natural log of X right so Ln of X of
time X is a variable of time remember
here we're only integrating with respect
to X and that equals what's the integral
of number times DT just that number
times T right lambda T and and I get a
constant right I always have an
integration constant because if I took
the derivative of this any number here
is going to go to zero okay so how do I
solve for X e to the both sides okay
so X of T equals e to the lambda T plus
a constant and the nice thing about
Exponential's is that e to the a plus B
equals e to the a times e to the B so e
to the constant is just another constant
just another number right this equals e
to the lambda T times okay another
constant okay we're getting there so our
function our population X as a function
of time looks like this exponential
function e to the lambda T times some
number K so what's K how would I figure
out what K is
well okay so what does initial condition
mean it means I look at what my function
was at time zero okay so if I plug in X
at time zero then that's you know X at 0
is e to the zero K e to the 0 is 1 so K
is my initial condition it's my the size
of my population at time 0 like right
now I have 50 bunnies in five years I'm
going to have e to the lambda 5 times 50
bunnies okay okay so the full solution
is X of T equals e to the lambda T times
my population at time 0 okay really
important equation simple but important
ok any any questions about Exponential's
the first order linear differential
equation now ok how many of you remember
what this number e means what it is how
many of you don't quite remember exactly
what he means I'm guessing some of you
because before I give this lecture a few
days ago I was thinking to myself what
exactly is e really ok so I want to
think about what is e the number e
really ok so how do we usually learn
about what e is like in school when you
learn about you what did your teachers
tell you
they told us about bunnies bunnies
procreating they told us about compound
interest
so compound interest I think is the the
absolute simplest way to think about
this because we get a limit out of it so
let's do that okay so we're going to do
a simple kind of problem this is the way
I like to do things is think about word
problems
okay we're problem solvers now okay so
I'm going to take out a loan L to buy a
car okay I need a new car my car's a
piece of [ __ ] I need a new car I'm going
to take out a loan and I'm going to buy
a car but I have an interest rate R and
so maybe every year I'm going to have to
pay our percent on the loan extra okay
something like that okay so there's a
few ways to do this if your bank is nice
they'll compound at the end of every
year so compound yearly which would mean
that so let's say that my my loan amount
is a variable X okay so X at time 0 is L
okay X 0 is my loan amount okay so if my
bank is nice and a compound yearly then
X of 1 is going to equal 1 plus R times
L or times X naught okay what are some
nasty tricks my bank can play on me
well they could change my rate now let's
say I have a fixed-rate loan they could
compound monthly okay so what that means
is that X at year one I took okay in the
first month I took my loan amount times
one plus R over 12 okay so now you know
I took my my yearly interest rate I
divided it by twelve and that's how much
my loan increased in the first month but
now in the second month I'm paying that
rate on my original loan amount plus the
interest I've accrued in the first month
okay so I do that over 12 months and I
get this nasty expression 1 plus R over
12 to the 12th power okay and this is a
little bit bigger than R it's not much
but it's a little bit bigger than R you
can use the same formula we used for the
power law okay and you can essentially
take the limit as your little delta T
goes to 0 and you can compound
continuously so my bank is compounding
my interest right now and now and now
and I'm paying interest on the interest
that I accrued in the last second in
this second ok and we find that you know
X at time 1 is equal to write the limit
as the number of divisions goes to
infinity of 1 plus R over N to the N
times X 0 okay and this is the
definition or one of the definitions of
e to the R ok e to the R is this limit
if you just compounded interest so this
is like my bunny population you know
it's proportional the amount of increase
to the bunny population is being
compounded continuously and if you take
that limit you get e to the R okay if I
pull up my compete
or let's see if I can do this and
actually get the computer to show okay
what was eetu the zero one right see if
this works
okay right so e to the zero was one
let's say that my interest rate is five
percent okay so after one year exp of 5%
or 0.05 what do we expect it to be about
well it's you know e to the something
small should be close to one now it
should be about one plus 0.05 right
because if I compounded yearly it would
just be one plus 5% but I'm compounding
continuously so there should be a little
bit more than 5% and I get one point
zero five one three okay so if I have a
5% interest rate and I compound it
continuously I'm paying about you know
0.1 three extra percent which is a lot
of money to banks right okay that's what
a means to me it's you take this limit
and you compound continuously so it's
the difference between discrete
compounding events and continuous
compounding events okay so the bunny
example is actually a little bit wrong
right do bunnies really compound
continuously no right maybe they're
compound once a year or twice a year or
three times a year
so I just want to think about I want you
to be thinking in the back of your head
if I ever say something that doesn't
sound right
think about what the assumptions were
that went into this okay
okay so let's think about another
example actually why don't we just write
down the interest rate problem kind of
formally right so what we're saying is
that the interest increases continuously
at a rate R that's proportional to the
amount that I owe so my interest rate
changes continuously in time at a rate R
that is proportional to my amount of
loan at time T right first-order simple
linear Oh de for the interest rate okay
and we know how to solve this good now
if we wanted to we could say that this
is the change in my interest rate over a
fixed amount of time like one month is
equal to R times my instantaneous loan
rate times some delta T so this would be
it what I wanted if I wanted to model
the bunny problem let's say bunnies
procreate twice a year okay then I might
write the system like this every two
times a year my bunny population
discreetly increases at an amount equal
to the rate of increase times that
population times that DT okay and this
is going to be the basis for numerically
solving these Odie's we're just going to
you know pick small D T's and actually
step these things forward so soon we're
going to do that okay good
what are some other examples of simple
linear first-order equations in
engineering
any of you live around Hanford
Washington yeah so what's the big
problem in Hanford waste right
radioactive groundwater so what is why
is this such a big problem what because
it heads towards the river I think the
big problem is that our favorite
radioactive material lasts for a
ridiculously long time
okay so plutonium has an incredibly long
shelf life okay so that's going to be
another example radioactive decay
radioactive decay so radioactive decay
we can say that the amount of
radioactive isotopes is decaying so
there's some - you know it's decreasing
at a rate that's proportional to the
size instantaneously of that pool of
radioactive waste okay so the number of
isotopes is decreasing at a rate
proportional to the number of isotopes
there's you know breaking occasionally
and so we know the solution to this this
is you know X of T equals e to the minus
lambda T times X naught okay so if I
have one pound of plutonium then at some
time T in the future I'll have e to the
minus lambda T pounds of plutonium left
over okay plutonium is nasty stuff you
don't need a pound pounds a lot of
plutonium okay so what we're going to do
is kind of turn this on its head so we
know what the solution is and let's say
that we want to solve for lambda okay so
I know what the half-life of plutonium
is okay so plutonium has a half-life of
about 80 million years
that's big okay so eighty million years
later I'll have a half a pound of
plutonium for my one pound that I
started with and using this basic number
everybody likes to talk about
half-life's but I like thinking about
what's my decay constant what's my
proportional rate of decay and we can
use that to solve for lambda really
really simply okay so we know that at 80
million years in the future when T
equals 8 times 10 to the 7 I will have
half of X naught left over okay so X
naught over 2 is going to equal to e to
the minus lambda times 8 times 10 to the
7 times X naught pretty simple right
this is you know not even calculus hey
we're going to cancel our x knots and
we're going to solve for lambda so what
is lambda equal it equals Ln of 1/2
right then I multiply both sides by
negative and I divide by 8 times 10 to
the 7 so minus divided by 8 times 10 to
the seventh okay that's what lambda
equals this is my decay rate my
proportionality constant we can plug it
into MATLAB you'd find that it's a
really really really really small number
okay so you can find out what lambda is
for your favorite radioactive isotopes
if you like what's any one other any
other favorite radioactive isotopes any
Russian assassins in the audience so if
I wanted to kill someone with a
radioactive isotope and I didn't want
there to be evidence what would I do
I would use something with a really
short half-life so what is so a really
short half-life what does that mean for
lambda big and negative right a big
negative number so who knows what a
really good radioactive element is for
killing Russian dissidents polonium
right anyone know what the number is I
don't either
okay what it 239 maybe
question mark okay so polonium has a
half-life of 138 days okay okay 138 days
is a little bit over 1/3 of a year let's
just call it 0.35 years okay so you see
that there's you know this huge
difference in half-life you know eat
orders of magnitude difference in the
half-life of this thing and we can solve
for the lambda constant in exactly the
same way so lambda equals minus Ln of
1/2 which is just a small you know a
positive number and now instead of
dividing by a huge number we're dividing
by a small number point three five okay
so this is now a much larger number and
there's always a negative sign out front
so this decays much much more quickly
lambda is much much larger okay 84 okay
way smaller 84 okay good
any questions about kind of this model
for radioactive decay this is actually
way way way way more accurate than the
bunny model right bunnies don't really
grow exponentially but this almost
exactly does decay exponentially right
like we're really relying on the
statistics of very large numbers if I
a pound of plutonium that's some
astronomical amount actually it's not
astronomical it's just a pound but it's
a pound of plutonium it's you know lots
and lots of atoms and they all act
quantum mechanically and so you know
this really is almost exactly a true
model of the system so it's also
something I want you to think of as how
good are our mathematical
representations where could error crop
in what does that mean when we have
error okay so I have one more example
and then I'll give you kind of a hint of
what's coming next week and that will go
for the weekend all right so the last
example is thermal runaway okay so how
many of you have suffered from thermal
runaway before I know I have one time in
college my computer caught fire because
of thermal runaway so who knows the
thermal runaway is exactly so there's
this unfortunate little quirk in some
silicon based electronics that when they
get hotter they become more resistive
and therefore they get hotter and hotter
and hotter and hotter okay and they get
hotter at a rate that's proportional to
how hot they are okay so we have the
temperature dot the rate of change of
the temperature of my you know my
transistor is equal to so some of you
actually probably know Silicon dynamics
and know that this is not actually right
but it's proportional to some number
times the current temperature okay this
is only in thermal runaway lithium-ion
batteries also going to thermal runaway
so the FAA actually has rules on how
many lithium-ion battery cells can be
packed next to each other on planes that
do have lots of passengers and planes
that don't have lots of passengers so
they're much more okay with a big FedEx
cargo plane going down with a one in a
billion chance but your passenger planes
actually limit how many lithium-ion
batteries can go in the cargo hold
of your plane because there is a small
finite kind of stochastic chance that
they'll go into thermal runaway melt a
hole in the plane and it'll go down this
this does happen okay so why okay so I
have some initial temperature T naught
it has to be sufficiently high that I go
into thermal runaway so there's a break
point now in practice why wouldn't my
temperature just go to infinity
all right so T at time T is equal to e
to the lambda time times whatever my
initial temperature was so if I let time
go to infinity this goes to infinity I
should probably draw an exponential okay
that's my exponential function e to the
T why does it my temperature go to
infinity sorry
external factors okay what do you think
okay well yeah what's another way of
saying thermal equilibrium
right so there's some amount of energy
flux out that's balancing this maybe
there are higher order terms as a
function of temperature like minus T
cubed okay so maybe I'm also radiating
energy at a rate T cubed or maybe T to
the 4 over 3 or I forget what blackbody
radiation is but there's some power of T
where bodies radiate out energy right
we're all doing it right now this remote
control is radiating out energy as a
function of its temperature and so this
addition of a non-linearity allows my
temperature to saturate at some very
very high value now that might be above
the burning point of the material ok or
it might not be so my laptop right now
is saturating because it's in
equilibrium with how much heat it can it
can draw out and maybe I put a big fan
on here and I multiply this by a big
constant okay okay that is my intro
lecture on Oh des these are the simplest
kinds of Oh de use this is really just
camp calculus ok we you know we have a
rate of change we manipulate our valor
variables we integrate them but very
very quickly we're going to start
looking at much more complicated Oh des
that model much more realistic system so
this tiny addition of this cubic
non-linearity makes this a much harder
and much more interesting problem to
solve ok so we're going to get into that
to do that we're going to start by
thinking a little bit more generally
about these differential equations so
I'm going to take the stiff eq x dot
equals lambda x and instead of just
assuming that we know a way of
integrating this using calculus or maybe
i know that the derivative right so the
derivative of e to the lambda x equals
lambda e to the lambda x right that's
just a fact from calculus that I know
but instead of assuming those things
next time we're actually going to make
another type of assumption that X can be
written as a Taylor series expansion
of time okay so it's going to equal some
constant plus another constant times
time plus another constant time squared
time cubed and so on ad infinitum and so
if you want to practice over the weekend
for for next week try plugging X of T as
a Taylor series expansion into this
expression and solve for what these
coefficients have to be okay and this is
really a way of deriving what e to the T
kind of physically means this is another
way of deriving e to the e to the T or e
to the lambda T and this is going to be
a very very powerful technique we can
use for nonlinear systems higher order
systems you know multiple independent
multiple variables that are changing at
once with with each other and so we're
going to start looking at higher order
equations like X double dot plus x
equals 0 we're going to look at
nonlinear equations like that systems of
equations and we're going to start
diving into that next week okay so we're
picking up steam we're going to go
exponential in the next few lectures
until we hit some saturation and then
we're going to just keep going at a
pretty high rate okay okay that's all
for today
Thanks
you